[Audience applauding]
- Now we have a small
but mighty virtual audience here today.
It's made up of all Marvel fans
and some of whom I'm told
have questions for me.
Hello. Hi, how's it going?
- Hey
[Inaudible]
It's so nice to meet you.
I am a huge fan of yours.
I'm also a mom of two little boys
who are even bigger fans of yours.
In fact, I have a five year old son,
Rowan, and he's really
into Marvel and superheroes.
So when Shanty first came out,
he just lit up when he saw a superhero
that looked like him on screen.
And actually it inspired him so much.
He wanted to sign up for
martial arts classes.
So he's doing that now.
He's loving it and he's kind of a shy kid
but he's really blossomed
and his confidence has just come out.
So, I wanna thank you for
being the inspiration.
- Oh my goodness. Thank you.
[Audience Applauding]
- So my fan question for you is,
if you could pick a film from the past
that you weren't in,
what film would that be?
And my question from my son Rowan,
is what's your martial arts move?
- Oh my God.
Great questions.
First of all, thank you so much.
Those are such kind words.
Movie that I would be in.
Oh my G.. I, my favorite movie growing up
was Jurassic Park and I just think
what an incredible film to be a part of,
I mean Spielberg obviously
a legendary filmmaker.
So I would go with either Jurassic Park,
or like Indiana Jones.
I feel like those would be
just such incredible adventures to be on.
And then in terms of
favorite martial arts movie,
oh, I gotta go with Rush Hour 2 actually.
[Audience applauding]
The scene in the massage parlor
is just absolute hilarious.
So, there you go.
Say hi to your boys for me.
Thank you so much.
[Audience Clapping]